the gold trade is a huge global business
the Philippines have particularly rich
deposits of gold but working conditions
and the mines are poor and child labour
is common brother as Erick and Jay are
dependent on their work in the mines to
eke out a living my name is rock stat
office part
we'll Eric and Jay managed to mine
enough gold this week to put food on
their family's table
this is the Philippines Gold Coast the
town of perikala is home to numerous
small gold mines
J and Eric work in one of them J is 16
and his brother Eric is only 14
sometimes I get worried that something's
going to collapse in the tunnel it's
dangerous the boys workplace is 50
meters below ground eric has a head
torch but no special protective clothing
every day he goes underground he dropped
out of school two years ago
this is the ventilation system that
provides air in the tunnel
the search for gold takes him deeper and
deeper into the mountainside often
dynamite is used for blasting breathing
is difficult down here but that doesn't
stop the smokers who work here it's
really hard the toughest part of this
job is mining the rock sometimes it
takes hours I'm doing this for my family
so my brothers and sisters will have a
roof over their head and enough to eat
but it's so hard
how many hours do you work here this
work is hard but we don't have any
choice we grew up with it it's the only
thing we've known since we were kids
several times a day Eric takes the rock
that he has hammered away up to the
surface
his father Paolo communicates with him
from the top of the mineshaft
Paulo has also been a minor since he was
a child the rocks ready to go okay boys
get going
the rope is manually operated during
power outages
Eric has mine 20 kilograms of gold or
this morning
the rock is crushed in this machine the
resulting sand is mixed with water and
mercury and forms a gold mercury amalgam
the next stage is the deadliest the
amalgam is heated up a number of times
to separate the gold from the mercury
the fumes are extremely toxic for the
workers and their environment Eric and
Jay breathe in these fumes day in and
day out
the end product a piece of pure gold not
much bigger than a grain of rice Eric
can't sleep long he has to go back to
work in the mine at night the next day
his brother Jay takes the piece of gold
to the Goldsmith's it weighs 1.3 grams
the day's work of some 10 people the
goldsmith doesn't earn much from the
transaction either the gold is worth 800
pesos about 15 euros
that money has to last a week
back home Jay gives his mother the money
that's not much just enough for rice
it's not enough but it's better than
nothing maybe you'll have more like next
time there are eight mouths to feed in
the family the youngest is just a week
old there's no alternative sometimes the
boys do other odd jobs on the side but
they never last boy
kids are banned from working in other
trades so they don't have any choice but
to work in the mines
Kadapa a thinker can attach a gauzy of
someone
the earnings were so meager that J and
his father head back to the mine on what
is meant to be their day off
the mines here on the mountainside
belonged to various small operators
according to local custom the ground can
hear and if a mine is productive the
owner is obliged to give a sack of gold
ore to the needy it's meant to bring
luck
thanks for the gift
J and his father immediately checked the
contents
J says these rocks aren't any good
they're full of quartz at least they
contain some gold but the quality is
poor the whole sack is maybe worth a
hundred pesos
that's enough to buy rice
there was a bad accident a while back a
worker was hauling sacks in the rain and
he slipped and fell into the mineshaft
they found his body in the tunnels
Manila
the gold miners put their lives on the
line but the environment also suffers
all of the chemicals flow straight into
the scene Jay and his father returned
home empty-handed they made the long
walk for nothing
kind of my I wish my children could
finish their schooling that way they'd
have the chance to do some other kind of
work and earn a regular income and they
wouldn't have to suffer like I do I
dream of finding a steady job to support
my family but I'd like most of all is
for my brother to be able to go back to
school I do the work of two people to
make that possible
you